grab some food cubes and
if you come before me then i'll slice
your head clean
well i'd be dead netflix germany's
latest sci-fi starring ulrich nielsen
depicts a post-apocalyptic europe where
man buns reign supreme and the
thunderdome is alive and well
welcome to another edition of
thunderdown
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into tribes of europa
it's cliffhanger ending and theories for
season two like what the heck is this
giant cube
who are the atlanteans and why on earth
would liv choose a crossbow when there
are so many better weapons
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe because if we lose power
i'll be out of a job
the final episode begins with moses
who's being interrogated by a group
known as the crows
it's the year 2074 45 years after an
event known as black december
a mysterious global blackout that caused
chaos anarchy and the complete
disillusion of europe now all that
remains are dozens if not hundreds of
tribes that fight for control of the
land one such tribe and one of the most
powerful are the crows led by
capitan evar they are searching for
something known as the cube a piece of
atlantean technology that could help
their tribe take over
all of europe in episode 1 we saw a
mysterious aircraft crash land near the
refugium the home of a tribe known as
the origins
it's ironic that an advanced piece of
technology lands here since
the originates have turned away from
technology and embraced a life in tune
with nature
elya a boy from this tribe finds the
cube and the injured atlantean pilot
bringing him back to the camp
even though the pilot's presence poses a
great danger to the tribe
the crows know of the crash and will
stop at nothing to get their hands on
that cube but as the crows descend upon
the refugium elia is tasked by the
atlantean to take the cube to something
known as the ark now there's not a lot
we know about the atlanteans
the name could hint at three things one
that they come from the atlantic perhaps
north america
after all the atlanteans speaks english
although with a
german accent atlanteans are also what
the people from the lost city of
atlantis recalled and considering moses
and elia descend into the water at the
end of the season
maybe there's something there finally
the word atlanta
comes from the greek titan atlas who
held the heavens on his shoulders there
are a lot of allusions to the heavens
aka space as the atlanteans seem to use
spacecraft and we see in the hologram
the cube unlocks someone wearing what
appears to be a spacesuit
is it possible the atlanteans come from
or live in space where the blackout
never occurred hence why their tech
still works
then there are the clues the atlantean
gives warning of impending doom if the
cube is not delivered to the ark
something is coming from the east
something dangerous the atlantean is
likely referencing something known as
the black swarm
when elia and moses meet a family on the
run from the far east they're warned
that if you see the black swarm
you die the cube's hologram recording
shows some sort of black swarm could
this be it and is it in any way
connected to the events of black
december
so the cube has to be delivered to the
ark just what exactly the ark is we
don't know
it could be a boat a spacecraft or
something else entirely
but the word arc is very specific it
makes me think of noah's ark from the
bible where the last of humanity
survived the catastrophic flood
could this black swarm be that new
catastrophic event and the ark is where
people can find refuge
moses also has a biblical name the man
who led the jewish people out of slavery
in ancient egypt is this foreshadowing
that moses will become that kind of
character it would actually be a great
character arc for him since he really
only cares about money and himself
it would be nice to see him change and
learn that people are more important
than profit
changing gears for a moment let's talk
about keanu the original's brother of
elia and liv who is enslaved and sent to
the volk factory where he soon catches
the eye of lord varvara he goes from a
slave class known as vobodnik working in
a factory where the average life
expectancy is three to four months due
to the toxic fumes
to lube nick which translates from
russian to lover and that's what these
garbage bag wearing slaves are to her
sex slaves keanu's refusal to obey
varvara's demands only make him more of
an interest to her as she slowly breaks
him down over the course of the season
his one desire is to compete in an event
known as
baj a one-on-one fight to the death
where the winner earns his or her
freedom well not exactly full freedom as
you become what's known to the crows as
a bose these ruthless warriors he
believes that by doing this he can save
his family particularly his father who
is being held as the capitan's house
servant and keanu's biggest heart of
darkness occurs when he's forced to
compete in the barge
against his own father killing him in
the process for varvara this was keanu's
chance to disconnect from his past and
start a new life as a bosey
habit
is sworn in and given the name tarak
he's even given this gas which were
never really told what it is
but the boses use it before battle so it
probably is some sort of stimulant
that's the last we see of keanu this
season and it sets him up for a very
precarious situation when his brother
and sister find out he killed their
father
i'm also curious if this is the
beginning of kano actually embracing
becoming a crow
if arvara keeps breaking him down i
could see him becoming this kylo ren
type character
waffling between both sides so it'll be
interesting where they take his
character
finally we have liv who's storyline i
found the least interesting as for five
episodes she's mainly confined to fort
arenberg which is controlled by a tribe
called crimson
crimson is made up of a group who wants
to go back to the old ways of the
european union even their uniforms are
hand-me-downs from that time
the problem here is a rift between its
leader general frances
cameron at david voss the general wants
to make a truce with the crows while
david wants them eliminated believing
crows can't be trusted
and they'll never honor such a truce
david so believes this that he ends up
killing the general and covering it up
to make it look like a crow attack
ensuring an
all-out war next season between the
crows and crimson david does however let
liv
live in this attack they had a brief
fling earlier on and he understands she
just wants to save her family what will
be interesting though is if liv will
reveal to others
david's treachery and if that will come
into play next season her only real
ticket to getting her family back was a
bosey prisoner by the name of grita
she was planning to trade her in
exchange for her family back but she
ends up dead
the end of liv's storyline actually
hearkens back to episode 1 which teased
her alone among a sea of dead bodies
what we didn't see in that episode was
her meeting with the feman
a tribe which seems to be based off the
femin a group of only women so it looks
like she'll be teaming up with him and
looking for a new way to get back to our
family we also haven't seen many of the
other tribes mentioned in the show which
i hope season 2 will delve further into
like the acon newlanders black skulls
and southern empire the season ends with
elia and moses
following the cube to a desolate
location south of berlin perhaps on the
mediterranean when the cube has
seemingly led them nowhere and runs out
of power elia in frustration throws it
into the water where it hovers for a
moment before plunging into the depths
moments later a
giant cube appears and what do you do
when a giant mysterious cube appears
you get into it of course and that's
exactly what moses and elia do
i don't think this is the arc itself
rather something that will transport
them to the ark it also seems man-made
judging by the caution tape-like paint
and the mechanical engineering this is
atlantean tech and as far as we know
atlanteans are human
the big question for season two is just
who these atlanteans are
how come they're able to use technology
and what do they know about this threat
to the east that could spell destruction
for all of humanity i also have a crazy
theory that elia quiano and liv's mother
chloe
isn't dead but that she's actually with
the atlanteans all we really know about
her is that she was
apparently killed by raiders and that
she had an infatuation with black
december
even cutting out newspaper clippings of
the event and collecting pre-black
december artifacts in a secluded cave by
the refugium
i could totally see her still being
alive and having somehow found the
atlanteans leaving her family because
something greater was at stake the end
of the world
that theory aside the show is actually
taking some cues from game of thrones
with the black swarm taking the place of
the white walkers and the rival tribes
being rival houses like the lannisters
and starks
it will be interesting to see how a
great external threat will change the
power dynamics between the tribes
and how this will affect the characters
reuniting thanks for watching everyone
please make sure to like and subscribe
and leave your comments and theories
about the show below
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you